Let's go next to our caller from the eight
four five area code.
Who's calling today from eight four five.
Hey David.
My name is Johnny.
I'm calling from Carmel, New York.
Hey Johnny, what's going on?
I was just wondering today, so everyone knows
basically your take on, uh, our prospects
for getting rid of Mitch McConnell in the
Senate in 2020.
Yeah.
And much as I hope you're wrong, I kind of
do agree that it is not going to be easy to
get rid of him and he's probably still going
to be there.
Yup.
Um, I'm just wondering what your take is on
Bernie's strategy of campaigning in states
where senators basically won't do what he
wants and hopefully rallying the people to
his side.
Yeah.
W so sorry.
You're saying people, senators won't do what
he wants in the sense that they're Republicans
is what you mean?
Well, yeah, he's mentioned it about Joe Mansion
as well, so it's not just republicans, but
like with his, I dunno if you knew this, Peyton,
Bernie recently took a trip to a Kentucky.
Yes.
He was basically campaigning against Mitch
McConnell and he's basically said that when
he's president he will be doing this a lot
more often.
I think it's great.
I think you take an hour of the above strategy,
but Bernie's savvy because when you go to
a place like Kentucky, especially during the
primary, you're campaigning for yourself for
the primary.
You are campaigning in a sense for Amy McGrath
who's running against Mitch McConnell.
You're, you're accomplishing a number of different
things.
You're talking directly at least potentially
to more red state voters.
And Elizabeth Warren has done really well
going into red states and talking to Trump
supporters and, and just talking sense into
thousands and thousands of them at all of
these different town halls that she does.
So I like the strategy.
I don't think he's losing anything by doing
it.
And as long as he's not only doing that and
ignoring for example, strategically important
states early in the primary.
I, I guess, are you concerned about the strategy
in some ways there's something about it that
worries you?
No, actually I'm, I think it's a great thing
personally.
Um, he, he, he's got this great image of just
like being willing to talk to anyone what
looks like during his, uh, his Fox News interview
when people were criticizing him for doing
that as well.
But I really was just wondering, do you actually
think that if Bernie ends up becoming the
president and we don't take back the Senate
and Mitch McConnell is still the majority
leader, do you think a strategy like that
would actually have any effect on Mitch McConnell
bringing things up for a vote, a vote, or
even like switching votes over?
It's possible.
I mean, if, if so, okay.
To play out your scenario.
If Bernie becomes president and the Democrats
extend or at least keep their lead, their
control of the house, but don't take over
the Senate, which is the most likely scenario
in in the Senate in 2020 I just don't see
the math for Democrats to take it over.
The scenario that might make Mitch McConnell
Stop the obstruction is if he understands
that with a popular Democratic president campaigning
against him in Kentucky, he may actually lose,
however, understand that they're only up for
reelection every six years, which means if
McConnell survives 2020 that gets him to 2026
I think he'll be close to 90 years old at
that point.
I don't know.
He must be at between 84 and 88 at this point
in time, so it's also possible that he just
doesn't care.
He is going to obstruct to the very last day
knowing that his 2020 reelection would be
the last one he's hoping for anyway, and it's
hard to have leverage over someone like that.
Yeah, that's really my main concern with it.
All right.
Thanks for taking my call.
David.
I appreciate it.
All right.
Johnny from New York.
I appreciate it.
Great to hear from you